advice to a friend who wants to become a
showrunner
do they really want to become a
showrunner i would question your sanity
are they a writer already
oh just just to say you had it sat down
and had a beer with someone that you
knew from a while back and they said you
know what i'm i'm here in la my goal is
to become a show runner watch this movie
yeah first start and read the book
and then come back to me and talk about
it we'll talk about it yeah
i mean it's it's the ambition of a lot
of people that we've met along the way
it is an incredibly difficult job to do
it's an incredibly difficult position to
get to in the first place however things
are changing a little bit there is a
little bit more opportunity there now
because there's now so many new outlets
coming out there's a lot of demand for
creative shows and stuff so
yes there's a greater possibility but it
is still an incredibly difficult job to
do and to get to
you